ارسل لك قوائم ارسلت بناء على طلب من
الاصدقاء وطلب من المحبين للشعب السوري
ولم يعني نطلبها لانه يعني بادرنا نحن
بالطلب هم سالونا ماذا تحتاجون وارسلنا
لهم هذه القوائم وجدنا منهم كل استجابه
وكل محبه فنحن لدينا مخزون اكيد من
الادويه ولدينا مخزون للطوارئ وموجودين
على الارض بكل الكوادر والفعاليه ما حدث
اكيد يسبب استنزاف للقطاع الصح المطلوب
منا اكبر تقديم الخدمه اليوم في المعاوي
التي تؤوي المواطنين اللي هربوا من
منازلهم المتصدع وهم يعني ممكن يكون في
عنا مشكله اكبر قد يواجه القطاع الصحي انه
هذه المباني قد تكون قايله للسقوط او
الانهيار او تقرر اللجان الهندسيه والفنيه
عدم صلاحيتها للسكن فاكيد هذول الاخوه
المواطنين واجبنا تقديم الرعايه الصحيه
الكامله لهم مع متطلبات الحياه الضروريه
شكرا
البريه السوريه
سؤال الاول معالي الوزير بعد اربعه ايام
تقريبا على هذه الكارثه الانسانيه فعلا ما
هي اكثر الامور الذي يحتاجها القطاع الصحي
والطب اليوم في سوريا الادويه ام الاجهزه
ام الطواقم الطبيه ام سيارات الاسعاف سؤال
ثاني لو سمحت مساله تحرير القيود على
القطاع الصحي في سوريا هل هناك مؤشرات
فعليا على هذا الامر تحدثت يعني بشكل كبير
عن مساله العقوبات وتاثيرها لكن خلال
الايام الماضي كان في كتير تصريحات من من
الدول الغربيه عن امكانيه وصول المساعدات
الطبيه او الرعايه الصحيه الى سوريا
اردتكم على هذه النقطه بالذات هل في
مؤشرات حقيقيه على الموضوع شكرا
استاذ نحن الموضوع ليس سجال الموضوع وقائع
ومؤشرات وارقام
واضحه ودقيقه لدينا في وزاره الصحه وفي كل
الوزارات السوريه
الجميع بيعرف انه قبل الحرب
الظالمه على سوريا وما فرض على سوريا كان
القطاع الصحي في سوريا مضرب مثل يعني في
المنطقه وهذا معروف للجميع ويشيد به الكل
حتى الاعداء يشيدوا به نحن اليوم بعد
سنوات طويله من الحرب تم استهلاك الكثير
من هذه الاجهزه صار في ضعف اكيد بتوريد ما
هو جديد
تم فرض عقوبات على الموردين وهذا واقع
وموجودين يعني ممكن سؤال والوصول لهم
بسهوله ولدينا البيانات نحن لا نتكلم يعني
انه
لنجد مبررات
حاجه القطاع الصحي بالدرجه الاولى بكل
تاكيد هو التجهيزات الكبيره هذا ما ذكرته
اليوم طلبه من منظمه الصحه العالميه اذكره
كطبيب لما بتنتشر المصاب من تحت الانقاض
في كارثه مثل في حلت بنا انت بتحتاج انه
تصوره
باجهزه باهظه الثمن لتوصل لتشخيص دقيق
لتقدر تساوي له اجراء جراحي صحيح مانو
الموضوع هو يعني عم نطلب وجود هذه
التجهيزات الكبيره والمكلفه ما عم نطلب
وجودها ترف والجميع يعلم ذلك والاطباء
يعني الكل ينزار سوريا وزار ما شافنا يعرف
هذا الكلام موضوع المشافي اكيد نحن بنحتاج
لمشاكل لانه كثير من البنيه التحتيه في
القطاع الصحي دمرت كلكم شاهدته لدينا كان
يعني مشفى اورام لداغي مشافي اورام كبيره
في العالم بحلب كيف تم تفجيره بالكامل
اكيد نحن هذا بيحتاج لسنوات للاموال طائله
نحن عم نحكي على الحاجه الطارئه الحاجه
الطارئه هي التجهيزات الطبيه الاساسيه
اضافه للتجهيزات الطبيه الطارئه سالت
زميلتنا سؤال يتعلق نحن اليوم بعد اربع
ايام على يعني لحظه الكارثه بعتقد تجاوزنا
جزء عام منا
اي ابلغنا ان طائر صينيه ابلغتنا لجنه ان
طائره صينيه تهبط الان في المطار والصين
حاضره دوما مع الشعب السوري كما ذكرت
واؤكد على هذه النقطه
فالحاجه بالمبدا للتجهيزات الكبيره التي
تعمل في المشافي
تليها الادويه وخاصه الادويه المشافي